the tones of joel mchale here on the
Richard ratio yeah you know it is a
thoroughfare right behind us here all
the AT&T employees or people who are
there malingering there was literally
yes don't they have jobs they wanted
you sound like Ted Knight from
Caddyshack don't you people at home
Johnny oh there's a you kids listening
to this show
go watch Caddyshack cause it's it still
works it's a delay it said delight when
was the last time you saw it Caddyshack
well now I'm promoting myself but I was
in a movie where I played Chevy Chase
and so I had to really study young Chevy
Chase to try and get you know kind of
his essence I worked with him on a show
called Parks and Rec for many years yes
I do recall that it was called community
rich I remember that in all seriousness
though I'm just trying to see how you
were trying to be humble
so I saw yourself so I would get the
name of your show is that Joel McHale
show with Joel McHale that's right one
would think that at this point in time
you know you just should go ahead and
put yourself on Parks and Rec and
community and people would believe me I
mean who what kind of an arrogant guy
would just name their own show after
them right perfect timing silly mug no I
think if you name your own show after
you then that's much harder to fire you
or they they're all because it's never
gonna be the Rich Eisen show with you've
sat in this chair yes but it was it was
it wasn't the Rich Eisen I guess it was
the Rich Eisen show with Joel McHale for
this day but there's no time if say it
going so well that they fired you and
kept me that's why I was here for one
day
they wouldn't it would it would be the
Rich Eisen show hosted by Joel McHale
hmm they would be a real awkward thing
so is this in your contract that it's
got to be called this was that was that
like your agent saying no Netflix
staredown with Netflix
no we we threw out a couple of different
titles and we at one point was gonna be
called Joel Mikhail's weekly dump and
the Netflix is like can you not call it
that but you could have gotten like a
coffee sponsor yeah
I don't even think about that come on
man nobody it's now a segment on the
show but it was gonna be called that so
you were able to use it we were able to
use a paul feig who produces it was very
every time we'd say weekly dumpy just
our laugh and he really wanted that one
which but I can see why Netflix I was a
fan of it twofold but I can see why
Netflix was not wanting that and then
number two from Netflix was the Joel
McHale show with Rich Eisen right they
were excited about that because that
left options open but they were they
were a little confused because a lot of
the you because in your verges a lot
you'd show a clip and then talk about
the NFL Draft which was not as it wasn't
I mean I it was funny but it was not as
connected as they wanted mom there's
some comedy in the NFL Draft yes which
my son he's now 10 Isaac he he he loves
what he loved watching the combine that
you hosted and he'll go just put
anything football on and I was like well
here's something fascinating watch this
guy run through some tires that are
lying on the ground let's see how fast
he can do it dude by the way there are
no tires in the ground well no it's not
like superstars it's true well let's see
here's like I mean it is yet similar he
I mean there is it's like well there he
goes and he's running there and that's
that and now here comes another guy and
he's doing the same now you can amend
yours like remember how he and that one
game did that thing now that was during
it game but now let's watch a bunch of
old dudes stare at a guy no you are you
may look I know that now people are
probably mad cuz they like the combines
amazing and uh but you make it you make
it very entertaining like well but not
you're not over excited about it which
is the way you can't get in there like
an American Ninja Warrior host and be
screaming and yelling and be like did
you see that
he jumped 36 inches three times in a row
I wonder if he'll do it again
problem is though is I'm in an open-air
booth oh and it is as quiet as a library
in there because that's only scouts and
coaches with there you can hear when
they're running a 40-yard dash you can
literally from where we are at the booth
position in Lucas Oil we're like Al
Michaels would be sitting for a game you
can hear the shoes on the ground and you
can hear the beeps of the watches so if
I starts screaming my head off like Tom
Coughlin's would turn around and give me
like the death stare and that I you
don't want to be on the business end of
that now do you think no I wouldn't
either
no but do you if the at do you think the
the athletes are just as motivated as
opposed to a stadium full of people in
game time oh yeah
if an athlete started going like yeah
I'm a I'm screwed yeah look at me yeah
watch this zig zag thing I'm about to do
watch me and do you think it would that
would throw the coaches off because we
like that person's crazy
well I think Baker Mayfield did that
actually oh no I'm just kidding but that
sounds like it sounds like something he
would do definitely it would change the
mood well I don't know certain coaches
might like that Bella check might
downgrade you know oh yeah because he's
real lively in those Prescott who was
your coach Joel McHale when you were in
Washington Hodge coach Don James so the
legendary yes Don James no I was how
would he have well he wouldn't really
make eye contact with me because I was a
walk-on and we were cattle and we were
the chaff
we were cannon fodder Ryan but when if
you did something good then he'd be like
hey that was good he stood up in a booth
because he he tried to watch the whole
practice like so height as everyone
knows I was the worst player in
Washington well history we're looking at
a shot of you standing in front of the
hose bowl right see that's the problem
is that I forgot my pads and so they're
like go back out to the bus and get them
and then they got that photo of me
you're in you're you're in your uniform
- pads room it looks like practice
shorts yeah no it's not game day itself
then right no there were been a lot more
people around and so yeah that's as
close as I got to playing I was in the
stadium but no I wasn't never even
in the game not even like I know I was
like I even like a Rudy moment for you
at any point no they would they broody
hadn't come out yet so they didn't know
about that moment and soon as that movie
came out I was like Oh missed my shot
yeah no I was I play I walked on and I
was awful and then they redshirted me my
second year and then I quit because
that's what you do to make it in
Hollywood
you you you quit jobs wait no your red
shirt I knew that I need it I was no it
was no now you were tied in right yes
the two tight ends in front of me and
the other eight in front of me but the
two were it was Marc Bruner and Ernie
Khan well who are they look like Greek
gods an Ernie was cleaning and jerking
365 when he was a 19 year old so he he
could bench 450 as a freshman and I ran
screaming and crying a lot on the field
and that's why no one could tackle me
cuz I felt bad that's usually I did see
one of the reasons I knew I should quit
yes I needed to get because I was doing
theater at night thank you and I saw
this player a huge scary defensive
player dislocate his hip and so his leg
was just sitting out and to the side and
I was like this I need I'm gonna get
hurt out here this is dangerous
and I love doing it but I didn't I knew
I was gonna be able to continue doing it
so I said I need to get some headshots
what was your 40 times John four six
five damn yeah for tight end that's ours
Ernie we ran a 4/5 for he was and he was
265 I was 245 oh that was the one I
could run fast cuz again it was all
fight or flight it was always what do
you know I'm a hundred and eighteen no I
am - I'm - 15 - between - 15 to 20 no
way
yes no kidding you wanna you're in
fighting shape I'm ready
you go to Netflix you have to get in
shape because they are you going is this
streaming everything around your channel
239 yes Channel five Oh 500 500 channels
6000 - yeah where that's and then PI
Omicron 1 1 4 that's which is being
broadcast on Jupiter right now
well hello to everybody in Jupiter we're
gonna take a 60-second break come back
and talk about the Joel McHale show with
Joel McHale yeah with Honda it's similar
the Rich Eisen show and again that's
kind of what I didn't in football that's
that was similar to my run do you have a
hip problem is that why you why your
Danny we're back in 60 seconds here at
Joel McHale let's talk about my pillow
your pillow hello my pillow comm promo
code rich radio listener special tab put
in that promo code or call eight hundred
676 when I sleep my pillow calm with
promo code rich better sleep starts with
my pillow now said you do that that
works when I lie on my side I always
pull them between my legs right I feel
like everyone does I works you know I
clutch one you hold on to it alright
something you know I don't know like a
butt between the legs is it important
move - yeah problems no you know I
started doing deadlifts like five years
ago and that fixed my lower back are you
serious dead serious yes deadlift
serious I what are you dead lifting
right now because it's not
counterproductive that dead lifting
would maybe help your back yeah it does
sound cuz there's the word dead in it
which tells you that something might
happen during it yes no I was getting
ready for a movie thank you so much
deliver something evil with Eric Bana
nobody saw it because it came out on the
same day as one of those Transformers
movie but it's really a movie I swear um
scott derrickson director but uh no my
lower back was always going out and then
I just be lying on the ground and then
this trainer named Ali grits said I'm
gonna fix your back wait who Ali grits
yes I know that sounds or greets it
sounds like okay she's a character from
a Western but she I started doing them
and I was like I was a whole new man
okay and so what are you deadlifting
right now how much weight yet know how
much like what are you putting on there
well I can deadlift quite a lot
thank you for a 46 year old man so yeah
I read when I when I'm going well I'll
do 315 three so three three plates of 15
three plates of 15 that brings the whole
bar up to 150 because the bar is 45 and
then each side a second see the reason
why I'm doing this is that that dude
over there
Mike dill to fo the other day said that
he could plank 145 and we're like 145
pounds just did 150 he said all the way
yourself 315 meaning 315 pounds not
three plates of 15 that's what I'm
saying he got the parlance of he said
when he said 145 he meant one plate of
45 I said 145 that's not that how you
talk that's not how a person talks
especially when you're talking about
numbers and then then you were able to
put 145 pounds yes weight on your back
Michael Irvin was barking it in and
you're not even in good form your butts
in the air
Thank You Joel Thank You Joel this I
have to do it again better no it doesn't
it how long did you do it for a minute a
minute that is the most unimpressive
physical feat that I've that's
embarrassing and you were sweating oh
yeah laughing so if you stick your butt
in the air you can take some and someone
just sets a plate on you you could hold
it there for a minute you're you're
dying you need to go to the doctor 60th
I'm sorry see now you can see that I'm a
jerk no no no it's all people like this
right Joel it's it's it's how much do
you deadlift I don't deadlift at all
do you exercise exercise I do Pilates
what was that head bob not easy you
don't have a Pilates body it seems okay
I feel like what does that mean how
often you do it once a week three times
a week that's impressive
thank you for an hour I mean it's a
bulky sweater how much did you weigh ten
years ago to ten and now you're to 1001
98 ok I've cut some weight all right not
like you I haven't cut weight from your
playing days well don't try to change
the subject okay you go ahead so no
other exercising other than Pilar I see
I just running for me is is why not a
rowing machine oh god that sounds like
death or one of those assault bikes
where you got to keep the fan going up a
certain rpm God my my those are really
good my wife wants a treadmill in the
house in the worst way we got to get one
yeah I do you want to get one of those
bowed ones we could oh my gosh really I
I agree with running it's hard on the
pounding is hard
yeah and I'm I'm pushing 50 how many you
are oh I thought you were way past that
no I'm so sorry
Joel McHale show with Joel McHale on
Netflix uh I was so thrilled to see you
do this
god bless you because you know what a
big fan I am Richard many times on the
soup I did many times yes which was an
absolute blast
god bless here odd the fact that it was
discontinued was a head scratcher to me
I raced I was right there with you I
mean cuz what we do in this world as we
consume all sorts of pop culture and
it's comes from everywhere and we need
somebody we need somebody to call it all
together and give us the most important
bless lame is the calling of all time
not at all well not at all
I mean there is a moshpit and we need
somebody like you in it hi yes damn if
the bachelor or the Bachelorette needs
to be made fun of I'm your guy now
imagine my
ancestors going Wow we had to cross
mountain ranges and oceans and go to
Ellis Island and start hard lies and
what is your what is what it what are
your future generations do you make fun
of Katy Perry's on-screen banter
on American Idol so they get enough of
it I can't get enough thank you let's
hope the world gets because we were
translated into 7,000 languages and and
I thought well I don't I don't know if
the people of the Maldives will want
this but darn it why I will proselytize
it to them any any day any ain't can
stream it all right now on Netflix
Kristen Bell she shared a little bit
when she was on the show or did yes
Kevin Hart Billy Eichner who's as funny
as they get out to Eric Bana and
mcCormick or Olson yeah and this week we
got drew Barrymore and Timothy Olaf
online a little Netflix cross-promotion
yes there's a lot and Adam Devine's
promoting his movie game over so
fantastic it it yes we only promote
Netflix now that that's where's uh where
is Olaf Anton are in our NCAA tournament
pool so he you know question we can pass
that information on to but while he's
getting that information Joel McHale
here on the Rich Eisen show your
thoughts on the Seahawks and what is
happening with them there's a lot as
everyone knows they better I'm from
Seattle and I love the Seahawks more
than my family and it's there's a lot of
changes happening and I hope it's I mean
they I trust what they're doing is is is
gonna work because there there was some
rebuilding rebuilding that had to happen
but I was sad to see Bennett go because
he's very good at football and Jimmy
Graham is too so III don't I don't know
you know better than me I'm not one of
those guys that keeps up one like well
this guy came and met and I know that
sue came and met but then we might not
get on went I know I don't know I
honestly don't know and whether he would
look I think he'd fit in anywhere but
the Richard Sherman departure for me
he's like he's a guy in the locker room
people will follow and yeah he was the
first guy with the you mad bro stuff
with Brady that really started put in
Seattle as a legit spot on the map for
football yeah that you better come in to
that spot with your big-boy pants on and
I know that Marshawn Lynch was there too
but he wasn't really much of a talker
right I used to but we still got that
Doug Baldwin who is a leader and of
course the great Russell Wilson who he
was the entire yeah he was the leading
running back so we need that obviously
has to be still almost 110 game I mean
when Steph that Blair Walsh had missed
that kick in the last game let's play
the last game that wasn't demoralizing
and uh and so I I i trust Pete Carroll
that he can he's of all the guy I mean
he's the king of Seattle so he brought
us a Super Bowl so and we want it so III
can't you know I trust that they know
what they're doing do you think they
know what they're doing I look they've
got a general manager and a coach that
knows the style and they have drafted
like all get-out
yeah I'm just look at all these guys
that are leaving they were all fifth
fourth sixth round draft choices the
exception of Earls Thomas who's still
around you know so well I would trust
them to is what I've said here before
that I need to see them struggle and be
an eight and 18 before I believe it I
need to see that you're never gonna see
that okay because we're awesome look at
you and we're gonna be fine no yeah so
I'm I'm I'm I'm confident Russell
Wilson's gonna be on the show really yes
you know you'll it's a great bit he does
he's very funny in it okay when does
that one hit that's two weeks so Russell
you see that must have been a thrill for
you to have Russell Wilson on the Joel
McHale show yes hell yes did you almost
rename it with with Russell well I would
have given him the he could have hosted
it he's he's it's so weird to its he was
walking around the offices I was like uh
there's Russell Wilson is that right
walking around the offices right now and
then you pulled him in no he was booked
on the show but there was everyone
brought out there there people were
there's a number of fans and he was so
sweet to them he was very nice it was it
made there's a woman who was blushing so
hard I thought we were gonna have to
take her to the emergency room
because she was so excited so it was
yeah he was he's really funny and I wish
I don't know if I should say the bit or
not the bits really good I guess I will
why not we're making fun of Frank
Thomas's new genex commercials so it's a
parody new genic so you cannot stop us
okay yes with Russell Wilson Russell
Wilson's at ease we can't wait for that
yeah so that's that's fun times he's
really funny innit the Joel McHale show
with Joel McHale this week with Adam
Devine the lovely and talented drew
Barrymore and Timothy Olyphant who is
where he is in fourth place he has 40
points however he had Xavier winning the
whole thing so he's out audio how's that
but how about that Loyola Chicago you're
your dad my dad went to Loyola Chicago
so your is your dad well he live in
Seattle or he lives in Seattle so
Gonzaga is in - oh so we're torn but
he's gonna go Loyola Chicago they're
both Catholic so he's gonna go Louis
Chicago all the way since that's where
he's from okay so that's a religious
thing is what you're saying
very move we've contacted the Pope and
he is praying what his bracket looks
though it's in Italian so it's hard to
it's hard to it's hard to read it oh no
that's a dead language come on they
don't they don't do that anymore they've
moved on you see how many people tuned
out during this interview zero don't say
those things I like to undercut
everything I've ever done
don't do that don't well thank you for
my club thank you for and I can the road
Callaway clubs to your to your right for
this entire interview I didn't notice it
at all and did you actually were injured
by almost a golf ball went flying past
me but I definitely got it was two for
flinching to use the I have definitely
been done that hate that's happened
that's happened it might hit me in the
shin and look what's happened to you
look at that this is fake it's it's
Hollow
that's right the Joel McHale not even
there with Joel McHale and his titanium
show coño it was a shot of you hitting
the ball in my directly flick alright my
cut the tail and see there's me
flinching as we go to break do you get
your sweaters for free
just tell us don't you have to buy your
own yes did you know Netflix bought it
that's why yeah I have a Netflix tattoo
on my Anna and a barcode they just beep
it and then give you a sweater it's 21st
century material good stuff
Wow nice way to wrap it up and now I'm
gonna go do a plank go for it go for it
yeah 1:45 I'm gonna do one we're
actually 45 do out the plates here if
you wanna my 70th birthday all right
we're back to wrap up the show I'm sets
up the rest of the week and a great old
gents debt based on the NCAA tournament
in Syracuse but what are we key who do
we plays no we're roll break the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience